hosting the grammys one time is a
lifetime achievement
hosting it twice is an opportunity to
mess things up so uh it's terrifying
it's exciting i haven't yet seen the
performances i got my peaches out in
georgia justin bieber just added justin
daniel caesar and givion um doing uh
peaches
we've been begging justin to come for
months it was always our hope that we
might be able to persuade him at the
last minute and and luckily we did so
yeah that's really exciting
from carrie underwood to bts and bieber
there are at least 27 performers lined
up for sunday's show on cbs it's an
enormous amount of pressure
if billy eilish wins record of the year
the 20 year old will be the first person
to clinch it three times in a row
meanwhile seven time nominee olivia
rodrigo is making her grammy debut
[Music]
songs is just my favorite thing in the
whole world and so to be recognized in
this way is absolutely surreal
[Music]
the foo fighters were set to perform but
pulled out after the sudden death of
drummer taylor hawkins e.t has learned a
tribute as planned in singing the in
memoriam broadway's best including
cynthia arrivo leslie odom jr and rachel
zegler
[Music]
some oscar stars are presenting
including quest love he seems over that
moment that overshadowed his win
tweeting can we finally stop talking
about it the slap how has that affected
your preparations for this show it makes
you it makes you more on your game it
makes you go oh yeah no we're doing a
live show for three and a half hours
where anything could happen
and then there's the kanye question
kanye is not performing is there any
chance that he could come or get
reinvited i don't think he was uninvited
he's always welcome he's nominated and
that's that
i'm always surprised on the night you
don't know who's going to roll out a
giant bed and twerk on it so
yeah this year i'm excited to see
anybody on stage